[Music]
chuck we're back okay for another
explainer all right all right this one i
did we talked about this before i have a
bad memory for what i've been talking
about but i'm gonna do it anyway and if
not we'll just do it again here it is
you ready
okay
so there's an interesting difference
between being an astrophysicist and
being a photographer
okay okay
here's the difference a college
education
okay here's the difference
we know
that when you have an object
and you heat it and as temperature rises
it it actually radiates energy
okay
ready if it's very cold it'll radiate
radio waves and microwaves in fact the
whole universe is three degrees absolute
zero uh three degrees above absolute
zero very cold at that temperature
microwaves get emitted
so the universe is a source of
microwaves upon us because of that
leftover temperature from the big bang
heat
anything more so i don't care what it is
heat it some more
and then
the energy it'll start giving us will
start shifting in the spectrum
and then it'll start giving us
infrared energy
okay you can't see it it's not glowing
visibly yet
but if we have sensors that are not our
eyes to detect infrared you know what
it's called
uh no touch okay touch it
okay
heat right yeah yeah if it's if it's
warm you can you can detect low level
infrared all the way up to high level
infrared just by getting near it and you
can feel the energy or you can touch it
and you can and you can feel the
temperature okay okay
so chuck it gets a little warmer than
infrared now begins to glow
red
and so now it's giving you
energy it's giving you photons in the
visible part of the spectrum say hey
that that's hot that's glowing red hot
right okay but i know
that you can keep making the temperature
higher
it'll still glow but now it's going to
glow white hot and then glow blue hot
and the blue hot is the hottest of the
glowing temperatures but we don't
experience that in everyday life so
we're gonna say blue hot anything
anything they don't say that anything
plus ice and icebergs have this blue
tone to them so psychologically it all
feels different but
here's what's interesting
okay
when we transitioned
from
incandescent bulbs the old old-fashioned
edison light bulb to leds
okay
ask yourself
why
would a light bulb giving you visible
light
ever get hot
because it's glowing white hot
but it's also still giving off infrared
okay so but wait a minute i have a light
bulb so that i can see
so the 100 watt light bulb or whatever
the wattage you bought
it turns out most of that energy is
coming out in the infrared yes
it's a waste
which is why they would always say on
the package it would say
um
wait
until wait for whatever you know however
long before changing the lipo because so
many people be like
like the light bulb would blow out they
would go get another light bulb
come back
we'll go to change it and burn their
hands that's how hot the bulb was
it's a complete waste of everybody's
energy
the fact that we have light bulbs that
was giving us infrared
wow
so
the brilliant thing about leds
and let me remind you leds are of this
next generation
interior lighting
we couldn't do it until we had all three
colors of leds
we had red leds right we had green leds
we didn't have blue
and that would once we got blue we'd
have rgb you can combine them
and rgb combined in light don't not
don't work this way in paint
don't tell your artist friends this
you combine rgb with light and you get
white light
the thing about leds is they're not
glowing
they're not glowing from heat it's
actual white light it's actual light
coming out at those frequencies at the
red frequency at the green frequency at
the blue frequency your eye merges them
and you see it as white light there is
no energy coming out in the infrared or
anywhere else
so that's why you can have a three watt
yes led bulb
that just kicks ass against a 60 watt or
however many five watts whatever and
that's a 60 watt uh edison bulb regular
old-fashioned bulb because most of that
interesting energy is coming out in
infrared and none of that energy is
coming out infrared for the led it's all
in the visible part of the spectrum i
don't know why we didn't do this one so
much earlier because
two things and it's so exciting that you
just actually
did everything you just did and
related it to light bulbs
one
people went crazy when
uh we said we were gonna transition to
all led light bulbs and they did it
because uh president blacula said that
we should actually
that we should actually
move
to all led light bulbs and people were
like ah now the government's trying to
tell you what kind of light bulb you can
have no i swear to god it's my god give
them right to have me a regular
incandescent light bulb that's america
and so people lost their minds this
church imitation of america
they lost their minds they lost their
minds and what you are saying is
one um
it's more uh it's it's more efficient
because it is exactly what it is which
is so it's an energy efficient it's like
a factor of 10.
okay and then the other thing you said
was that is why
you see on the box it's whatever many
watts
instead of like your 200 watt bulb or
whatever it's like you know it says if
they do lumens now yeah you can't use
watch because you know what watts are
watts is not the measure of the
brightness of anything right what is the
measure of how much energy the rate at
which it's consuming energy
and since we all had the same light
bulbs you could compare watts and say
that one is you know twice whatever you
had you had some
sense of that right but
really with light bulbs it should have
always been measured in lumens in fact
in europe i think they always measured
it in lumens so you really you're after
lumens here you're not after wattage
okay
so this is a maturity of the american
population yeah it's this is this is the
best reason for your people to go out
and get led lights i mean for me you
know i got into this because it's great
for the environment you know if we all
did it we would really lessen our carbon
footprint for the entire nation but the
fact is here's why you should do it you
save money you just you just proved how
much more efficient it is you save your
own damn money correctly even if you
don't care about the environment care
about your own damn wallet right so and
that's why you can go up to any led bulb
and it's not hot it'll never be hot
it's not about being hot
and hear these people earth is flat and
i don't like science and all the the
person who discovered
the blue led got a nobel prize for that
because the moment that got discovered
it blew open the entire lighting
industry
because now you can make white light in
fact you can make any color light that's
why you can get led controllers
where the the light itself has an rgb uh
diodes in them um
and you can just control the ratios of
those and get any color you want
and so you can the empire state building
is lit by these things okay
and it's very int the intensity of the
color is very real and it's very in the
in the moment so
so just thought i'd tell you that that's
super cool well listen
white light was
what we were striving for but always
remember
only black light can make your dorm room
look cool
[Laughter]
oh by the way so black light just to be
clear is an ultra violet light but the
part of it you see is the violet
that's just kicking into the red on this
yellow green blue violet part of the
spectrum you can see that but that's not
why you have it in your dorm room you
have it because the ultraviolet light
interacts with the pigment in the
pictures on your wall the posters and it
forces the pigment to glow
okay
and
it it it's called phosphorescence right
and so that high energy light that you
can't see the pigment can't see it
absorbs it and then gives it back to you
in visible light and it looks like the
paintings are glowing so in a sense it
is black light it is light that you
can't see
nice
yeah all right
well this was great you got it chuck
so next time you walk by a a an led just
pause and say
thank you science
there you go
just say that anyway
just say that anyway
wake up in the morning take a deep
breath thank you so much science
i should tweet that i'm going to do that
let me see if i can start a movement so
chuck we got to call this one quits i
hope you enjoyed this one always always
very good very good neil degrasse tyson
here as always
[Music]